I left to take Johan bronze Johann
Strauss II J Strauss I have a feeling
that we meet Leon 339 55 still applies
well onward by way of introducing our
next messengers I'm reminded that I had
to make at least six films before my
name came a household word in my own
household these two did it with the very
first appearances she is the
extraordinary young beauty in ordinary
people and he is the glib young con
whose performance in 48 hours gave the
rest of us that much time to get out of
town Eddie Murphy and my lovely patient
from lovesick Elizabeth McGovern
a trip did you see me tres
well that was just what I like I'm not
cool anymore no Eddie in this category
it's for Best Visual Effects you know
before we get to that you know what I'm
thinking about
mmm-hmm what Anke yes ten women in the
audience it's been like a week or so
we're gonna get picked for like the
worst best-dressed at the Oscars and
people Maggie and I think that's funny
what were you gonna say you be serious
all right
this is that in the category for Best
Visual Effects the nominees are douglas
trumbull richard yurich and David Dreier
for blade Richard Edlund Michael Wood
and Ruth Nicholson for fuller diamonds
collar Rambaldi Dennis Muren and Kenneth
F Smith the et the effort history and
the winner is the winners are Carlo
Rambaldi Dennis Maryland
accepting the visual effects award for
et the extra-terrestrial color Rambaldi
Dennis Muren and Canada's
I like to thank my collaborator and the
member of the Academy for recognizing my
work they are in the technology which
gave et life thank you very much
equalities excellent work in the other
nominees in this category and thanks
very much to Mike McAlister the Mike
Penn Gracia in the math department and
Steven Spielberg for excellent excellent
direction I like to thank Dave berry and
Ralph Gordon and Mike foamer and Charlie
Bailey and a special thanks to my wife
Zahra thanks Steven